[Applause]
fortunate to be sitting here with mr
david bowie
thank you for doing it my pleasure thank
you for performing for us that was
terrific oh that that was that was
there's some great shirts in the
audience look at that shirt
that's how we recruit all right there's
a man dressed uh completely in silver i
believe
that's right
there we go
wait a minute
he liked the shirt yeah the guy's like
thank you thank you yeah
you know there's so much to talk about
and uh we're always trying so little
time and so so little time then we turn
to the big tooth i'm not even gonna
mention this
carry on what are we gonna say well uh
you know what i it's it's famous uh
famous lore about you and i've never
actually asked you you've been on the
show several times about your name yes
it's a famous thing now that your name
initially
davey jones yes it was davey jones and
in the 60s you had to change it because
the monkeys came along and they were
just getting popular when i was just
starting my career so i very wisely
changed it to tom jones
true story true story i was tom jones
for about a couple of weeks and just as
i was doing the photo session he
released his first record it's not
unusual and so then i moved on through
then you were david cassidy that david
cassidy
yeah and you're like wait a minute sean
cassidy yeah he'll never make it yeah
okay very nice then it would have sean
pan and just
slightly better so it basically took you
years yeah to get on the right name now
something that came out about you
recently and this maybe this is
embarrassing but i thought we have to
bring it up you were recently named the
25th
richest man in britain that's got to be
uh yeah
yeah
woo you've accrued great wealth
yeah right that's something
uh
what a craftsman
piece yeah yeah that's right
once was a mime always a mime the pine
right
walking against the wind yeah yeah yeah
okay we'll get you to do some mine next
time yes we will
we're gonna loop what you just did over
and over again and make you look insane
yeah
but what's it i think it's been done
already i think
i did that i did that myself
successfully oh you've done that okay
you've already made yourself look insane
i would think that would be difficult if
it gets published that you have all this
money how do you give people gifts at
christmas if you can't just give them
like it's
it's a shoe it goes inside your shoe and
it keeps its shape
it's i mean that's not going to do when
you're the twenty five string of islands
oh you've done that yeah a string of
pearls string of islands
what are you shacky green
is this thing working that came after
sean cassidy but i just you tried
checking green yeah green didn't happen
for very long
that was 1972.
uh you had a um well it's 1970.
trust me
this is gonna be a famous interview one
day
once they figure out what the hell we're
talking about this
when they released the transcript of
this did you know that we got to shaking
yeah that was my plan though that was
pretty i wanted you to talk about checky
green why was it you had a songwriting
contest a while ago yeah tell us about
that i didn't win
you you invited people all over my site
i i put up a melody and a chorus and i
asked the users of the site to
contribute lyrics and the uh winner came
to the studio and we we put the song on
the album ours
the new album
exciting
thank you was that over ours the new
album yeah
the consummate businessman amazing now
the 24th richest man
the uh you know i find out about this
contest and i'm a bit of a songwriter
why would you laugh at that and i
i submitted a song did you get my song
i didn't win and i was i thought i'm
sure we saw it yeah
i thought my song was really good
and i thought maybe you hadn't you know
you must have gotten a lot of
submissions but since you're here now i
thought i should show my song
to david bowie
in fact i have it right here
and i thought maybe you'd perform it
right here and we'd see who had the best
song huh
[Music]
you don't mind do you
okay here we go
it's in g you like g huh i love g okay
i'll live for g here we go i'll get you
in the mirror
[Music]
there are so many talk show hosts
but he is clearly better than most
[Music]
he's a handsome man but i'm not lying it
should be and and i'm not lying
this wonderful name is
conan o'brien
hold on
that's the good part here here's the
good part
ground control
[Applause]
how about huh
you've busted your g string
how about
how about big red
dumb
what are you babbling about i thought
the lyrics were good i think it kind of
falls apart at the end but i thought uh
it was very nice of you to do that what
do you think
but you're supposed to be such a nice
guy yeah uh we have to talk before we go
about this uh you've come out with a
game
oh my god oh my god
what
what
you've come out with a video game
you sir
are a wise ass all right
careful i'm talking about the bucket
under your desk all right all
that's what's right the bucket show show
everything i have a bucket under here
and you keep commenting on it rehearsal
but look what's behind the bucket a
brush that's right
[Applause]
david letterman has nothing under his
deck
oh there's something down there all
right let's uh
we have a clip here of the game uh and
in this game you uh it's a city that
you've created this specific well i
didn't create this was invented by the
french therefore there's a lot of strip
bars red light districts smooching
couples gorgeous women really yeah it's
it's quite fantastic it's uh it's so
french that the guys on the street hey
and they come at you with guns and they
say i'm gonna what are you reading
you really william gibson
verlaine that's all right celine
what kind of video game is that well we
have a uh we have a clip here do we need
to know anything or should we just roll
it i'll just roll it okay
you're not the first video game player
to get your soul trapped in this
dimension
[Music]
there was a naked woman in there
you can't show that
it's almost 1 30 you'll get in trouble